seventy-five years ago 50 countries
signed a charter that changed the course
of history the United Nations Charter
marked the start of a new world order
its founding principle was international
collaboration today nationalist agendas
and great power rivalry threaten the
future of the global organization we
asked Antonio Guterres the United
Nations secretary-general whether the
organization is fit for purpose in the
21st century the UN 75 multiple crises
and new challenges you said yourself
that these are dark days how would you
define the biggest challenges I said we
have two kinds of challenges one is the
fact we are an intergovernmental
organization and as an inter government
organization that has bobby's like the
General Assembly or the Security Council
it depends on the capacity of member
states to come together special when we
have such dramatic challenges as the cop
in 19 or climate change or the impact of
new technologies in our economies and
our societies and the two seas that we
have now a very dysfunctional
relationship namely among the three
biggest powers and that this functional
relationship makes it very difficult for
the Security Council to take adequate
decisions in addition to the major
crises we face and it creates other
difficulties in the way the organization
works the other challenges that are more
related to our own activities the
Secretariat organization is of course
they need to be able to make the
organization more nimble most effective
more cost-effective and we have devoted
ourselves very strongly to the reform
the internal reform of the organization
as if we made a lot of progress on that
but there is still a long way to go
if you take your first point that the
relationship between three major powers
is dysfunctional with it
this is hardly new for the United
Nations what makes us different from you
take the broad sweep of 75 years of
the United Nations how has this changed
the present pattern is relatively new we
have of course the Cold War and the Cold
War has its rules there were two
superpowers essentially those two
superpowers were confronting each other
in many aspects but to a certain extent
everything was predictable then we had
the period of I would say American
supremacy the 90s I was prime minister
of Portugal and again the rules were
clear now it's much more messy we have
three powers the United States China and
Russia but the relationship is very
dysfunctional it's very unpredictable
it's much more difficult to create an
international environment in which the
spoilers are forced to play by the rules
how much more difficult is it made by
the fact that America has stepped back
to some extent from the world we already
saw this under President Obama
nation-building at home but now we see
this even more with the Donald Trump who
is for example pulling America out of
the United the World Health Organization
can the UN function without an engaged
America I don't see the international
community can leave without a strong
engagement in the United States in
international affairs if we want to
promote the number of key values so
democracy human rights and others where
I believe the President of the United
States and the function United States
would be extremely extremely important
but you're very careful in how you treat
President Donald Trump for example you
made the critical an American policy
you've never criticized him by name is
that a deliberate strategy I do not
believe that in international politics
it's good to enter into personal
confrontations with whoever that leads
nowhere and I think I have a major
responsibility to preserve United
Nations and to preserve a functional
relationship without the key partners of
the United Nations including obviously
the United States and what about the
other major powers first of all China
you've been criticized for not speaking
up loudly enough on human rights for
example for with China how do you handle
this question of trying to having a very
different view of human rights the most
spoken question when we talk about human
rights related to Chinese of course the
legal question I had the occasion to
discuss it several times with the
Chinese authorities to make it public
and to clearly assert that human rights
need to be fully respected they're more
than that that in situations where you
have a minority it is absolutely
essential that all communities feel that
their identity is respected and at the
same time that they are recognized as
part as the community as a whole and
let's not forget Russia its asserting
itself more and more and vetoing many UN
Security Council resolutions how do you
how do you handle the the somewhat
disrupted behavior of Russia and how do
you get towards a Security Council that
can actually agree on things I was
definitely simpleness to tell the truth
and to make the proposals that make
sense
independently of sometimes being in
opposition in relation to the positions
of the Russian Federation just to give
you an example we have been very clear
in recent times asking for cross-border
American aid to be possible relation to
Syria and so this has been a bone of
contention in relation to the Russian
Federation in several moments at the
same time it's to recognize that the
Russian Federation the pressure of the
Syrian government to allow for the
constitutional committee to move forward
Russia has brazenly grabbed a piece of
Ukraine China has occupied disputed
territories in the South China Sea these
are exactly the kind of areas where we
would expect the Security Council to be
active has it become too slow and it is
it not being challenged enough to do the
job it's there to do
is not an abstract entity it is an
acting with member states and five of
those member states have a veto right
and we know that whenever there is a
very serious question related to the
israeli/palestinian question the
Americans will veto we know that there
is a serious question Asia to Ukraine or
to Syria the Russians will veto and we
know that there is something on the
South China Sea or equivalent to China
will probably veto so we know that this
is the reality but I also think that
people tend to look into the I mean the
when as a huge activity in the world
that sometimes ignored we recently
launched a global response package
humanitarian response package for the
Pahlavi 19 to support 110 million people
in 64 countries and these on top of all
the other he managed an action we are
providing is my challenge to you I
suppose I wondered whether in your view
the UN was pivoting towards judging
itself by its successes in terms of
humanitarian relief refugee crisis and
the other things that it does in that
sphere World Health Organization etc and
last about security we are at the
present moment deeply engaged in Yemen
trying to bring together the parties to
the conflict to reach an agreement and
we we have been more far away we have
been very actively engaged and I myself
have been on the phone with the key
actors of the conflict and with the
regional powers and the global powers
for that our objective is to have a
global ceasefire in Yemen we are doing
the same very actively engaged in
supporting the peace process in
Afghanistan we are extremely engaged in
Libya and it must I must tell it's the
biggest frustration at the mall because
we're the spoilers are
simply undermining the chance of a
ceasefire in that context but at the
same time in Syria I think it's fair to
recognize that we have been able to
bring together the parties even in it's
very difficult to make problems but the
constitutional committee was created and
that was an achievement of the when
diplomacy now the truth is if we have a
United Security Council if we have a
functional relationship among the
superpowers then of course things will
be much more easy then of course our
action would be much more successful
could I talk about the relationship
between China and Russia which seems in
some ways to restored kind of character
that talks back to the Cold War in in
many respects and I'm wondering what you
think the implications of that are you
diplomatically saying it it's obviously
good if you get more cooperation between
the major players but in some ways it's
not so good if two of the major world
powers who have anti-democratic use
leanings are budding up together
[Music]
situation in relation to the future I
think it is defined by the present
circumstances to a large extent but we
look at the challenges of the world
today there is an absolute need for
countries like Russia China the United
States to be able to understand that
they need to work together to mobilize
the whole of the international community
for those challenges to be faced
positively means by the change pocket 19
or other similar aspects can I turn you
to the future of the UN here we are 75
the institutions are really quite long
in the tooth a they should they should
rightly have some reform to modernize
them but is reform impossible given
these divisions
the top one of my main objectives in
everything I've been doing is exactly to
reduce the bureaucracy anywhere and to
make the minute you have much more
nimble and much more effective and I
think we made some meaningful progress
on that exact of course it's a huge
transformation also in the system of
power in the organization but having
said so I also think the UN needs to be
humble and needs to listen and that is
the reason why instead of using the 75th
anniversary to launch I would say a big
campaign to promote the UN we put us
exactly in a listening mode and we
launched a huge survey and a huge debate
at the global level the survey that was
done in cooperation with several
entities have already 222,000 answers of
people coming from one other than 93
countries telling what they think about
the future what should be the priorities
of the International Corporation are you
hearing things in this great exercise
that to some some extent surprise you
and make you think that the UN needs to
change course in some ways there is a
huge that it's a huge request of
accountability accountability of the UN
accountability of government
accountability of institutions and the
transparency and accountability probably
the two most important demands that I
feel and that I will do my best to put
in the center of our reform concerns in
the world
again back to the grand sweep of history
what do you see the next period of the
UN heralding we've got 275 years take us
forward to a hundred years there are two
dimensions that I believe are absolutely
crucial for the intervention of the UN
in the future one is climate change and
the other is the digital world we have
today a situation in which it is clear
we live in law with inner lawlessness in
the cyberspace we see artificial
intelligence developing at fantastic
and we do not see effective mechanisms
of governance it's clear those
mechanisms cannot be the governance
mechanisms of the past the UN is better
placed at any other organization today
in the world to be that platform where
different entities government civil
society businesses science come together
and try to find the mechanisms of the
governments of the problems of the
future until you go cherish thank you
very much for joining us
it was a pleasure this interview is from
our show The Economist asks and every
week we publish a new episode in which
we interview key figures in world events
the link opposite will take you to a
page with all of our previous episodes
thanks for watching